peu
[Musique]
nous
15 juin trois milles au large de
monte-carlo altitude - 307 m pression
trente et une atmosphère
[Musique]
v1 sortir ouais
on fera ça faisait sous lâché veut
ensuite de récupération
la sonde extérieure
évolution puis descente vers le rap aux
opérations saturation des corners à nous
permettre d'évaluer nos procédures
d'intervention jusqu'à la profondeur de
300 mètres avec plongeurs à partir du
bâtiment
riton spécialisé pour les plonger à
saturation
ce bâtiment met en oeuvre un ensemble
hyperbare dans lequel vivent les
plongeurs la pression équivalente à 250
mètres de profondeur également de
landrush dynamique qui lui permet de se
positionner sur un point choisi sur le
fond à partir du triton lato elle est
descendue sur le fond et les plongeurs
ont une activité à nos sur le chantier
sous marins ou sur la tâche à réaliser
[Musique]
le petit sous-marin griffon qui est
impressionnant c'est rick nous informer
des activités des plongeurs également
apporté son soutien au point de vue
projecteurs effectué également les
prises de vue et puis au point de vue
psychologique il était quand même
important d'avoir un soutien sur le fond
encore évoluer en nageant sur 300 mètres
de profondeur
il était agréable d'avoir ses camarades
dans le petit sous-marin
je voulais ça permettait d'annuler un
petit peu la barrière du néant qui se
trouve tout autour de la tourelle car il
n'y a pas un halo de lumière le 10
mètres environ autour de la tourelle et
pour le plongeur qui sort cassé
[Musique]
intervenir pensée profondeur et quand
même éprouvant mais nous pensons que
actuellement les plongeurs peuvent
évoluer dans la tranche de profondeur
qui va jusqu'à 400 m quels résultats
peut-on tirer d'une telle expérience
elle vient pour nous ce résultat est
intéressant car il nous permet
d'intervenir pour les besoins dans la
défense jusqu'à la profondeur de 303 cm
c'est à dire récupération d'objets sur
le fond informations renseignements sur
le fond et dans le cadre du sauvetage
des sous-marins et d'une façon civile et
sur le plan civil mise au point de
procédures ou décident équipements pour
nos camarades et civils
mais selon michel roques veillée répéter
nous n'avons pas compris vous au feu en
a fait de même de rappeler points alors
quand vous
alors
[Musique]
les quatre sous-officiers mariniers le
groupe d'intervention sous la mer
peuvent s'estimer pleinement satisfait
aujourd'hui des plongeurs entraînés sont
parfaitement capables de descendre à
moins de 300 mètres de fond ou effectuer
des tâches bien précises et au delà ses
prouesses techniques et humaines pour
bien comprendre la satisfaction des
participants à cette opération
il faut se souvenir qu'il y à 7 ans
encore on estimait que l'homme ne
pourrait jamais descendre en scaphandre
au delà des 150 m pourtant à force
d'études sur les mélanges gazeux étude
réalisée en étroite collaboration marine
nationale société civile
à force de recherches sur le matériel et
sur les problèmes posés par la
décompression
il semble aujourd'hui une étape
importante a été franchie dans
l'adaptation de l'homme au milieu
sous-marin la descente a de beaucoup
plus grande profondeur semble maintenant
acquise dans cette perspective en
novembre prochain
le vice maire avec l'opération janus
tentera de descendre encore plus profond
au large de la norvège
[Musique]
alain colas sur le chemin de la guérison
le navigateur a effectué une première
sortie de l'hôpital de nantes où il se
remet lentement de l'accident qui a
failli lui coûter le pied il espère bien
être l'année prochaine à la barre de son
voilier géant pour le départ de la
transat
il ya des jours où l'on peut regretter
de ne pas être anglais surtout pour le
départ d'une course comme la cooper s
qui sait donner à londres le 31 août
dernier
les concurrents vont tenter de rivaliser
de vitesse avec les fameux clippers qui
transportait la laine d'australie en
angleterre au siècle dernier et qui
n'hésitait pas à risquer leur précieux
chargement pour arriver les premiers et
vendre leur laine au meilleur prix
actuellement en tête de la course un
seul bateau français kritter 2 ketch
d'acier de 25 mètres de long ont barré
par olivier de kersauson l'ex seconde
eric tabarly le termineront en vous
présentant bruce premières stars
d'hollywood cette année et rôle
principal du film lloze aucun numéro un
au hit parade cinématographique des
états unis
[Musique]
la voile française au cours de ces
dernières années a pris son essor du
petit dériveur d'initiation à la machine
de course olympique
le nombre d unités à flot et celui des
pratiquants s'est accrue et une vitesse
vertigineuse
si les progrès ont été rapides en
dériveur léger et si les français furent
souvent habile et brillant dans les
courses solitaires comme la
transatlantique ou dans les courses
lointaines l'admiral's cup
elle leur a toujours échappé la murale
scop est un espèce de championnat du
monde de gros bateaux qui se court tous
les deux ans en angleterre
c'est un défi que chacun porte à
l'angleterre et nous sommes trois
bateaux par nation des bateaux
relativement important puisqu'il s'agit
de bateaux ayant un minimum de 12 mètres
jusqu'à environ 4 16 17 m
de plus en plus la course de haute mer
tend à devenir une longue régate son
temps par là que la technique qui était
jusqu'à présent employé sur des courses
de cases mamie ou parcourt l'afrique
devient pratiquement la même sur des
courses qui vont même jusqu'à 600 milles
cette année pour la première fois et
pour la dixième admiral scop la france
présentait une douzaine de bateaux
candidats à la sélection et il fallait
en choisir trois
nous avons fait des épreuves de
sélection au mois de juin
préalablement nous avons entraîné les
différents bateaux pour essayer de créer
un esprit d'équipé tout à fait
nécessaire pour ce genre de compétition
des qui vient à l'encontre de l'esprit
individualiste d'abord des français et
ensuite des gens qui font de la voile et
est assez difficile de créer cet esprit
d'équipé
[Musique]
l'admiral scop secours en manche et donc
on pense qu'il faut courir les
sélections en manche qu'il faut que les
bateaux se prépare en manche
il faut donc que les méditerranéens
accepte de monter leur bateau
suffisamment tôt pour faire connaissance
avec la manche qui est tout de même très
différente de la méditerranée il est
certain que cela engage 9 des frais
importants au niveau des transports des
équipiers et on n'a pas encore trouvé
une formule pour arriver à alléger le
budget des skippers méditerranéen
les français ayant enfin compris qu'il
faut se préparer ensemble en 77 il
faudra compter avec la france
le
e
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
4 août 15h feu à bord d'un yacht anglais
les deux occupants parviennent à quitter
l'épave quelques secondes avant
l'explosion ou crossa les veilleurs
reçoivent l'appel de détresse mayday
mayday mayday
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
en pleine croissance
[Applaudissements]
sur les côtes 24 heures par jour toute
l'année
soixante sept personnes sont en veille
aucun appel aucune fusée rouge d'où
qu'elle vienne n'est laissée sans
réponse
c'est ainsi que 4600 personnes ont pu
être assisté l'an passé
[Applaudissements]
rabon des dragons des dragons du procès
remontant des mots également mondiale
recevoir un message de détresse d'un
bateau de plaisance qui a coulé dans le
suroît je répète suroît de la pointe de
l'échelle
deux personnes à bord dont une blessée
ils tentent d'évacuer ce radeau
pneumatique zone de recherche entre 180
et 240 distance à prendre une à nouveau
reçu au nom voilà la bonette affaires
maritimes harmoye sur zone dans comme
étant sur zone jeu mais n'avons aucun
contact
[Musique]
il faut d'abord si nous dire ce que
signifie le cycle cross le cyclo-cross
signifie centre régional opérationnel de
surveillance et de sauvetage
il y en a trois en france d'un père
façade maritime
le cros marins portés jobourg le crossa
implantée à vittel le crossmed
implantée à toulon avec des sous des
antennes qui sont gris nez et permanent
pour le cros marc soulas permanent pour
le crossa et des antennes saisonnière
camaret pour le crossa et agde en saison
estivale
le rôle du cross et de faire de
recueillir l'alertent et de faire cette
coordination qui est nécessaire je
voulais pour mener à bien ce que la
sécurité des gens en zones côtières
[Musique]
on savait qu'on a bien voulu le dire ou
non la vedette à moi sur la zone
préparez-vous à toyer le bcm
québec deux potes effectué quelques pas
de son livre jeune femme de charlie
bouviale tard métal corrodé fait
beaucoup maintenant tous les patients
ont coulé dans les faux voire de la
pointe des chaînes intégrées de
personnes à bord sont blessés et
restauration s'étaient battus
ça
pendant son tour
[Musique]
la vie humaine n'a pas de prix sont
allés lumens et gratuit alors comment ça
se passe en fait pour l'année dernière
14 en gros ça le coût des moyens mis en
oeuvre a été de 4 millions 4 278 milles
francs l'eau alors comment ça se passe
chaque administration supporter propre
fait par exemple les côtés la protection
civile qui intervient de kérosène qui
est consommée c'est la possibilité qu'il
offre un pay day que la des moyens
côtier s'avère insuffisant et en hiver
en particulier par certains types de
temps ils prêtent missile de mettre des
moyens côtier à la mer c'est les gros -
la marine nationale qui interviennent
droits par des moyens lourds des coûts
de chair des deux tiers de cette somme
sont
ce sont des pensées ce monsieur le
budget de la marine de la marine
nationale
il est important que les alertes
transitent par les cross toujours dans
le but de secourir les gens le plus vite
possible
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous recommandons aux plaisanciers
d'informer les crosses de leurs trajets
et de leurs dates probables d'arriver à
destination
s'il s'arrête en chemin pour une raison
ou pour une autre ils doivent le faire
savoir afin que l'on ne voit pas la leur
secours les moyens nécessaires à ceux
qui ont un réel besoin d'assistance
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
l'initiation à quoi au dériveur pour
mieux te présenter j'ai tiré sur le
sable et j'ai disposé à ses côtés tout
ce qui est nécessaire pour le manoeuvrer
correctement
[Musique]
maintenant vu de l'avant c'est la partie
du bateau que l'on appelle la coque
elle est en plastique qui n'ont pas eu
d'entretien et ça selma qui supporte la
voilure creux en bois ou en aluminium
comme celui ci posée sur le fond du
bateau il est soutenu par trois fils
d'acier
à l'avant les terres et sur chaque côté
les hauts blancs
[Musique]
m
celle est qui non c'est la dérive de son
puits ont la baisse ou dans la relève à
volonté au tableau arrière le gouvernail
composé d'une planche en bois mobile qui
plonge dans l'eau appelé safran et d'un
bras de levier que l'on appelle la barre
l'action de la barre sur le safran
dirige le bateau dans un sens ou dans
l'autre
[Musique]
nous devons repenser la voile qui va
nous faire profiter du vent et glisse de
petit lac qui vont l'attendre pour nous
éviter de battre ses poils autrefois en
coton aujourd'hui en tergal il ya un
sans fil et parrain de ces trois côtés
par la gorge d'une pièce de bois qu'on
l'appelle la bonne tu suis c'est pas ton
compliqué
à l'avant on dispose d'une seconde voile
petit que l'hôte que l'on appelle le
phoque comme l'animal nous n'aurons f
hausser de forme triangulaire on la fixe
à l'extrémité du bateau au point d'un
mur de l'été avant la d3 fil d'acier
dont je t'ai parlé avant qui tient le
mât on attache l'autre extrémité du
phoque à une corde que l'on appelle la
drisse et il ne reste plus qu'à lui
c'est le flou qui sait on vient la grand
voile dont on fixe la baume ou ma part
une sorte de charnière le vit de mulet
qui permettra d'orienter la voile à sa
convenance
on dégage alors la drisse de grand voile
et on y fixe la voile par son extrémité
supérieure par une pièce métallique
triangulaire que tu peux voir là la
têtière non non rien du vent mistral gel
la manoeuvre on commence à hisser en
veillant de garder le bateau faso
pourquoi si le vent vient de travers la
voile peut donner prise et le renverser
la voix lycée il ne reste plus qu'à
fixer la drisse ont fait plusieurs tours
au taquet à la base du mas à droite on
en soigneusement il ne reste plus qu'à
porter le bateau à l'eau cela fera
l'objet d'une prochaine initiation
larabia tôt
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vendredi 27 juin 14h sur l'île saint
germain à issy les moulineaux
gérard moreau procède à la dernière
inspection de coke dans moins d'une
heure
le voyez nouveau né sera mise à l'eau
[Musique]
on
je trouve formidable de voir
et tout ce garçon qui sont
sont lancés dans cette affaire que
l'idée est venue de deux amis serge
binotto gérard moreau qui faire du doigt
perdu un trio mena'sen désert en
afghanistan ont bien décidé qu'un jour
une naviguerez plus comme bateau l'idée
née de là et puis
le projet a pris corps nous s'est
retrouvé femmes sont retrouvés à
proscrire en bateau puis aujourd'hui
vous voyez que ce n'était pas une idée
si pour lui que ça c'est d'abord
beaucoup documenté on est allé voir du
chantier naval où la très bien été
accueillie nous expliquer comment
procéder
et puis on a appris disant nous mêmes
j'ai décidé d aider parce que qu'est ce
qu'on en fera on n'est pas des oisifs
on a l'habitude de travailler parfois
très dure pour nous mon bas c'est normal
[Musique]
par obligation
[Rires]
monsieur représentants du secrétariat
d'état à la jeunesse et aux sports
monsieur le maire d'issy j'étais à
remercier toute l'équipe qui m'a choisi
amen et je te baptise le patriarche
[Applaudissements]
oh non c'est par ici
à mettre fin au blocus
et
[Musique]
j'avais le trac pourquoi et qui va
flotter
je rigole mais n'a misé sur qu'il a
bluffé tout un bateau goélette à demain
ego de 28,50 ducret 23 mètres de long
pour tous et 21 mètres 50 sur le pont de
la surface de voilure au près sera de
335 mètres carrés le lest de 9 tonnes il
ya 4000 litres de 2000 litres d'eau et
2008 des poux dans les allées souhaite
faire le triangle atlantique qui est une
course qui va être aussi assez
passionnante sur les parcours saint malo
saint malo le cap le caprio et rio pour
seulement deux ans six mois et 13 jours
de travail de joie de découragement pour
tous pour aboutir à cette extraordinaire
instant l'acquis de patriarche la
pénétrer dans l'eau bien sûr le bateau
est encore loin les terminer il faut
encore le matd et l'armée l'équipe et le
régler avant qu'ils puissent s'aligner
au départ d'une course et maintenant le
plus dur est fait et pour les quatre
amies
le rêve fou qu'ils portaient en eux
construire leur propre bateau est
maintenant réalisé
[Musique]
m
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
e
non
[Musique]